hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 27th of May today and you're tuned
into games but news another battlefield
game may be in the works according to
information pulled from Battlelog source
code the game which may or may not be
happening is called battlefield hardline
and the logo for the game as well as
references to xbox 360 xbox one ps3 ps4
and PC were dug up on EA's or in servers
the unofficial battlefield daily Twitter
account has been collating icons and
images that are allegedly from the game
including stacks of weapons and vehicles
as well as a visceral games logo
suggesting that the dead space creator
may be developing the title given Sony's
a lot so awesome profits of late Sierra
casa rice that they want to push the ps4
to drive users towards its network
business the company recently posted a
1.2 6 billion dollar loss and expect a
post another in the coming year to
remedy this they're planning to entice
users to the playstation network as well
as to their other services like who's
extremely and video downloads toward the
end of this year that will also loop in
the game streaming service PlayStation
now now now I've got some good news and
some bad news the good news is we got
some new footage from the order 1886 and
the bad news is that is delayed till
next year developer ready at dawn has
announced that the ps4 exclusive won't
be coming this year because they want to
deliver on the experience they promised
the game is set in an alternate version
of Victorian era London and you embody
Galahad a member of a group of knights
if you want more information on the game
check out Maxwell's preview on games
what now in other the order related news
developer ready at dawn who said that
the game will run in 30 frames per
second because 24 frames per second just
doesn't feel good well yeah that's
because it's 24 frames per second we
already knew what the frame rate would
be but director dana jen has said 60
frames per second is really responsive
and cool i enjoy playing games in 60
frames per second but one thing that
really changes is the aesthetic of the
game in 60 frames per second we're going
for this film
look so one thing that we knew
immediately was films run at 24fps we're
going to run a 30 because 24 FPS does
not feel good to play John went on to
say that 60fps would have made the game
looked like something on the Discovery
Channel or a syfy original movie which
wasn't what they were after let me know
if your came to pick up the order next
year and if you think the game is gonna
be any good in that commenting section
down below you can also chat to me on my
twitter where i'm at jess mcdonald those
are all the things that i wanted to tell
you about today but tomorrow i'll be
back with even more news so I hope all
season